As you have seen, the president of the
European Commission Ursula Fondarlain
immediately accepted the invitation I
had made to her to come here to Lampedusa
to personally take stock of the
situation
but I want to say that I do not consider
this so much a gesture of solidarity
from Europe towards  Italy, I consider it
rather a gesture of
Europe's responsibility towards itself because
these are the borders of Italy but they
are also the borders of Europe.
And if someone in Europe thought that
faced with the global crisis that we are
facing, the issue could be
resolved  simply closing it
within the Italian borders would
clearly take a Baglio. We
are faced with such a scale in
terms of migratory flows that if
we do not work
seriously and all together on combating
illegal departures, the numbers of this
phenomenon will overwhelm the border states first.
But  then everyone else and
therefore the problem is a problem which
inevitably involves everyone and which
must be addressed by everyone
and the presence of the president of the
Fonderlian commission this morning
I believe gives this sign of
awareness that
the future that Europe wants to give itself is at stake here
because the future of Europe
depends on Europe's ability to
face the great vocal challenges of
our time and that of
illegal immigration is certainly
one of these vocal challenges, President
Fonderline knows this very well, which is why
I also want to say that the  I have found her to be
collaborative from the beginning of our
work, I have always found her to be collaborative
and I believe that this is very important,
we need serious, complex and
lasting solutions and we also need to
all work in the same direction because it wouldn't make
much sense to see one part
of Europe making a commitment  and works to
find those solutions and another
part of Europe that for
ideological reasons works to dismantle that
work and those solutions
I continue to say that faced with the
flows that Italy is facing that
Europe is facing we will never resolve
the  problem by talking about how to
redistribute migrants within
European borders, the only way to
seriously address the problem and to
ensure that the solution for one
nation does not mean creating a problem for
another nation and working on the
external dimension and stopping  the
illegal departures of immigrants This is what
European citizens ask of us but I
want to say that also what
regular immigrants ask of us the many
regular immigrants who live in Europe
and what refugees ask of us who
really has the right to be a refugee
because not always  we were able to
deal with everyone also for the problem we
had with illegal immigration
what are these solutions these
proposals
what Italy
is carrying forward from the teachings of the new
government and on which we found
common work with the president of the
European commission  structural agreements
with the countries of North Africa to stop
the departures also to avoid the drama
of deaths at sea
more incisive fight against
human traffickers Even by standardizing the
legislation of the countries involved
you will remember that we organized a
conference on development and
migration with everyone  the countries in the
enlarged Mediterranean also and
above all to work on this
front
legal immigration quotas
agreed
above all with the countries that collaborate
in the fight against illegal migration
an effective European naval mission
to combat smugglers and
irregular departures
and more effective tools for the repatriation
of immigrants  illegal that are
put in place by the European Union not
by individual national states and then I
also believe we will talk about it this week that
a greater involvement of the
United Nations is also absolutely necessary at this point
the first signs of this strategy which
strategy which is shared by the  '
European Union from the European Council this is
what the conclusions of the European Council say
is a memorandum that we have
signed with Tunisia a very
important signal for which I want to
thank
Ursula melterlien on which we must today
be able to be fast and incisive for
the implementation and realization of the
memorandum which can be preparatory
as the president is also involved in
other agreements with other North
African countries and demonstrates a Europe that offers
its contribution by asking for a
contribution of responsibility in exchange
[Music]
are the themes that we will bring to the next
European Council in October
I trust that the solutions
will arrive also because in recent
days I have spoken with various leaders of the
European Council and I am
optimistic that the
Italian position, in short, the position that I have
told you about, is also widely shared
within the European Council
[Music]
In the meantime I confirm  that in
tomorrow's Council of Ministers we will bring the
law to extend
the detention for the
purposes of repatriation of those arriving
regularly in Italy to the maximum permitted by European rules and we will give
the Ministry of Defense a mandate to take
immediate action to create these
structures that are necessary
I close by thanking the Commissioner for
Internal Affairs Johansson who came
here today to accompany the president
of the President Borderline the Minister
of the Interior plants doses the President
of the Region Renato Schifani the
deputy mayor of Lampedusa and I want to
thank him by thanking the citizens of
Lampedusa
with whom we spoke this morning
They are people who have always faced
an extremely difficult situation. We
continue to find very
responsible, very very
nice people. I was pleased to have
the opportunity to meet them and
talk to them. We are committed to
making their conditions
on the island better. We have already done so.
with as you know with an investment of
45 million euros for the Island precisely
to help centrally manage
some issues on which the
municipal administrations, being
small, may not have the resources and the
necessary tools but I really want to
thank them also for their
welcome in a  difficult moment like
this
Thank you very much president please
[Music]
Thank you very much Thank you very much Giorgia I
also want to thank the President of the
Region I want to thank the
deputy mayor of Lampedusa I want to
thank you it is very important for me
to be here with you
today for me Because writing is a
European  challenges
because immigration is illegal it is a
European challenge and therefore needs a
European response
[Music]
and Lone forcement personnel
In These Days of
managed to this Island we
met the incredible citizens
of Lampedusa we spoke with the
hotspot staff and  obviously
we also talked we
really met the fantastic fantastic
population it was fantastic
civil protection and the
representatives of the police force
in these dramatic days the
local community continued to do its
utmost to be able to give support to the
men, women and children who
arrived  on this
incredible island truly warms the heart
and it is very important to remember one thing
everyone involved be it the
inhabitants of Lampedusa or the
local authorities or Migrants are involved in
a situation they are imprisoned in a
situation that they did not create and it is
continually increasing  the number of
emigrants who leave their country
of origin are people who are
lured by ruthless
men ruthless traffickers
and many arrive here in Lampedusa
simply because of its geographical location
this places Lampedusa under strong, very
strong pressure creating an
extremely difficult situation for
its population President Meloni and
myself Today we are here to
offer a coordinated response from
the Italian and European authorities but
I want to be very clear we have an
obligation as part of the
international community we have tempered
this obligation in the past And we
will continue to do so today  and in the future but
we will decide who arrives in
Europe and under what circumstances not the
traffickers
I would like to
present you a 10 point action plan
First of all the support offered
to Italy by the
European Commission by
the Asylum Agency of  European Union by
Frontex to deal with the
immediate crisis the agencies can help
manage the high number of migrants and
can also lend a hand in
registering arrivals
identification and so on
second
revivals Out of Lampedusa entry search
to Used
solitaires Out  of Italy
secondly we will increase our
support for the transfer of
migrants
by taking them away from Lampedusa we urge
other Member States to make use of the
voluntary solidarity mechanism to
transfer migrants out of Italy
mystert Point we of depapport of French
Toons Swift
Country of  Origin of age of Fire
Silent
cannot Stay In the Europe
this
sand vice President Margareth Skins to
Diet and to speak To The country's
origin
thirdly we offer support in the
face of experiences guarantee a rapid
repatriation of migrants to their countries of
origin of those who
those who do not have
the characteristics to be able to apply for
asylum are not entitled to asylum and cannot remain
in Europe and we will also turn to the
countries of origin to facilitate this
process and I will send the vice-president to
speak. In this regard with the
representatives of the  countries of origin
must Step Up or Effects to Fight this
countries of Origin and the countries of
Transit to crack down on this brutal
business
therefore
Tunisia and Lone the root of
legendslation on antis Marlin needs
update from theagal
fourthly we must increase
our efforts  to fight against
traffickers we must join
forces with the countries of origin and the
transit countries to be able to
crack down on this
brutal business we need
a joint approach for example
frontex europol which collaborates with
Tunisia  along this route and we
also need to update and amend
the legislation relating to the fight against
traffickers the first Step Up
Survival
16 Nations
place we will increase surveillance both
by sea and air and we can do this
through Frontex. Furthermore, I give my
support to the possibility of exploring
options to be able to expand
existing or existing naval missions or even
consider the possibility of starting
new ones in the Mediterranean
we will also accelerate
our supply of equipment to the
Tunisian Coast Guard
verses
Logistics of
Origins to One shower and Destruction of
ricken cuprated bolds
in sixth  place we will act against
logistics against the organization of
traffickers In the sense that we will
also collaborate with the Italian authorities to
ensure that all the
boats and
all the vehicles used for
the transport of migrants are removed and destroyed
Applications that a I'  m Found
Police for Silence a Silence have to be
Turn
and the seventh point the European
asylum agency is ready to increase and
further develop its support
to Italy to speed up the procedures
relating to the granting of asylum it is
very important to
reject
asylum requests that are unfounded quickly and those who do
not have the right and title to receive
asylum must return to their country
and Connect
Effect Manager
is the last point which, linked to what has been
said above, is the most effective measure to
counteract the lies of  traffickers
are the legal arrival routes
we must be able to and
obviously the humanitarian corridors which are
extremely important we must offer
emigrants real alternatives
through humanitarian entry and
this is very important because only in
this way can the Circle
of narrative be broken  lying on the part of
traffickers
And then because this is an
extremely important and connected thing
The better the better and better
we are in managing
migration and legal migration the
more rigid we can be with
illegal migration which also brings me to the ninth
point  namely that we will increase and
expand cooperation with him nhcr
and with the international office for
migration to ensure the protection
of migrants along the route and
also increase assisted voluntary returns
[Music]
this brings me to the last point we are
collaborating with  Tunisia for
the implementation of the memorandum of understanding
which will allow us to accelerate the
conclusion of new projects and therefore the
disbursement of funds from Tunisia
now
all of you again migration is a European
Challenge and and this is and Solutions
concrete actions Darwin Change on the
Ground
and this Only This solidarity
Union Italia can count on the European Union
and I would like to conclude by saying that I
came here to tell all of you that
migration is a European challenge that
requires a European response and solution
and it is with concrete actions that it
will be possible to bring  change in
this field in this sector and it is
only through
solidarity and unity that
all this can be achieved and you can count on
the European Union
We have time for three questions before we
have to start again for
we must remember that the president
of the European Commission has delayed
his departure for New York to be
here today we are Time
of Us
I'm Virginia piccolo from Corriere
della Sera so I will try to be
comprehensive so maybe it answers all
everyone's doubts I wanted to know as
President Borderline
yours you have  having seen the hotspot now
even if in some way it had been
very efficiently cleaned up from the
dramatic situation of the last few days you
have seen the island what was not clear about
this situation We listen we say
promised we are told that there are
indeed important signals from the Union
European what has not been clear why
we have arrived at this situation
because here we say The opposition Maybe
thinks that perhaps it was
this government's fault of previous factors
because we only listen to the headlines we
say about what has to happen and we
never see how it happens and  then I also wanted to
know from President Melone but
also from herself, President
Fonderlain and here the
health workers are also asking for example that it is not just
let's say the tough face and also they are
also a little worried in view of the
European elections that there is let's say a
challenge to  show that those who are more
rigorous but also humanitarian things
for example there is a new emergency
pregnant women we saw a
newborn die on the balcony four days ago
because they leave believing that there is
Youssoli here and many pregnant women find themselves
in very fragile
exposed situations let's say the
difficult situation of the hotspots in
difficult situations we can think of a path to
solve this problem thank you
kind President von The Line have you
been
yourselt the hotspot
is replying no go Hello
we have excellent corporations of
the first time in the
europe
implementation of this time Points in
Reaction Plans
[Music]
stupid Management to
But first of all as regards
this situation of this reason
why we have clarified we
came here and I have been extremely
clear there is this  discussion of
collaboration with Italy and for the
first time in any case in the European Union
there is also a discussion of strengthening and
implementing the various mechanisms and various
agreements which are also fundamental for what
concerns asylum and is also
extremely important  it is important
to define the rules which are fundamental
precisely for the application of the
routes of those
legal migration routes and having visited
having seen and we
absolutely must be extremely
operational and this is the reason why
I have explained the action plan in
these  10 points that must be implemented
in a specific way also because this
obviously requires involvement and
requires participation as well as
responsibility, we must join forces
to also be able to address the aspect and
the discussion of the humanitarian corridor,
arriving at the point you raised for
what  it concerns pregnant women who
come here who embark in order to try to
get here to Italy.
This is the further
confirmation of how ruthless and
liars the traffickers are who make millions
and millions off the skin of these people
by lying to them  and
luring them into this trap
by putting them on boats that
are not even able to navigate,
making them risk their lives and
this is the reason why we must use
a strong fist, we must break this
cycle and we can do it because it is
organized crime therefore
with the collaboration of europol of euro
Just with the authorities of the various countries it is
important to break all
this by showing
the alternative of the legal
arrival route and the possibility of
always maintaining the humanitarian corridors it is
possible to break this cycle in some way
and help this circle help
people to understand that
if people are attracted and
rely on traffickers spending
a lot of money losing all their
money they arrive illegally and are
brought back where instead
they follow the regular route they are and
can be welcomed and received
by Europe  and those who are
entitled to it can have their
right to asylum guaranteed and we have also spoken
with the minister since we have
also spoken with the authorities of the
Italian Civil Protection precisely also
in order to be able to continue to collaborate in
this sense, I
add very quickly that I have
always  considered that the routes, let's say,
for the transfer of migrants who arrive
should be different routes between, let's
say
[Music]
single men of working age to
understand each other and
mothers and those under 14 and also the subject
of the measures that we will take tomorrow
in the council of ministers where there  'It is
clearly a hypothesis of detention
for the purposes of repatriation for up to 18 months which
above all
concerns Franci less. Here we say
so while I believe that the issue of
women and minors under 14 years of age should be treated separately since the
president quickly entered into
Next European Council on the
migrant issue I officially ask you if there is
acceleration on Tunisia's funds
and on the naval blockade and
concretely what it would be about
and to the president Fondoliner English
Etneas Edition
representative of the one of the
biggest strategies in the Mediterranean
See You Remember
The Trooper 2017
Do you have the
politically with your reactive Action
Plans
that it you Fair to face the migration
Emergency
European Union Thank you
No oh well she did it in English
she to her
she understands from the answer ok why let
's go right then I'm going fast
fast
So I spoke about the topic of the European Council
on the phone obviously after
having sent the letter with the
president short Michelle. I am waiting for
an official response but I want to tell you
that I am optimistic, let's say that it will be
discussed. Also because in
recent days I have spoken with  many
of the leaders of the European leaders of the leaders
of the European Council and they are all very
sensitive to a matter that they understand
to be of relevance for each of us
on the topic of Tunisia President
Fonderlaiem responded clearly We
are for um unlock that is to unlock in short
to accelerate as much as possible  possible
not only the implementation of the
memorandum of the first part of the
memorandum also the implementation of the
second part of the memorandum which provides for
an investment in Tunisia to support
development and something that in my opinion
should also be discussed at the European Council and
the hypothesis of a  support for the
Tunisian budget which is independent of the agreement with the
International Monetary Fund.
In this regard, we have an option to
invest resources that we have
linked to the agreement with the
International Monetary Fund but perhaps
the European Union could and
should also consider supporting the
budget in this regard  Tunisian without hooking up
hooking up the agreement To the International Monetary Fund
for what you what what
concerns the naval mission
I continue to say what I have always
said that the only serious way of
dealing with this matter is on the one hand let's
say to help the  authorities of North
Africa to manage the flow of those leaving. These
are initiatives that must be carried out in
agreement with the North African authorities. In the
past, European naval missions have been carried out
which have had the limitation
of sometimes representing more of a
pulfactor, i.e. an element of push for
migratory flows rather than
blockades. However, I believe that we need to
think about starting again from what was
the second and third part of the
Sophia mission which was never
carried out because, as you know,
precisely because
the first part of the Sophia mission revealed itself to be a sort of
pulfactor then does not come
the other two parts are not implemented the one In my opinion it
is entered from which We
should start
[Music]
and as regards your question
relating precisely to the attitude
of the European Union as I said I
spoke I  continued to speak
with the other leaders and the idea was
exactly that of jointly addressing
these migratory flows in a responsible manner, the
challenge was exactly this, it must be done
together, it must also be done starting
from the experience of managing the flows
not only at European level but  also
at an international level, therefore trying
to apply those systems and
mechanisms that have worked. They have
been successful, they have been sustainable. And in
any case, I reiterate the application of the
points I spoke about. It is also
fundamental to clarify that the routes and
illegal arrivals involve
repatriation and  return those who do not have the
right to stay return home while
the illegal routes are opened and enforced
Thank you all sorry we have to
escape